thursday as we look out we've got some
color we've got a few high clouds off in
the distance there kind of covering up
the sun which
is not up yet but as soon as it starts
rising it's still got to
get above those clouds i just want to
call your attention that as you look off
to the east this evening
don't forget with clear skies you should
be able to see saturn in jupiter
and that waxing moon meaning the
building moon as we get towards another
full moon now
on halloween evening oh that is going to
be so fun
to have a full moon on halloween a week
from saturday
lots of 60s around the valley this
morning 51 up at kyle canyon
we are going to get these numbers way
down come this weekend and into next
week
we're looking at big cool changes for us
57 in nellis right now 61 at sunrise
mountain
66 still at anthem mountains edge at 62.
outside the valley we're definitely
cooler
56 in mesquite 67 at red rock with a
breeze there
but up in lincoln county caliente is
down to 37
and there are actually freeze warnings
posted for tonight into tomorrow morning
already ahead of the cold system that's
going to dive into the intermountain
west
and the desert southwest look at the
snow through the rockies and the upper
midwest
there's cold air that's going to invade
the center of the country and the desert
again those freeze warnings are for
tonight up in lincoln county
while fire weather warnings with strong
gusty winds tomorrow
for utah we're looking at just a big mix
of weather
as we head towards and into the weekend
89 today no different really from
yesterday
with warm conditions hazy sunshine
we start to see temperatures go down a
little bit mid 80s southwest wind
saturday ahead of the system
and we're looking at maybe a little
mountain snow
on sunday with a slight chance of
showers sunday night
and much cooler temperatures next week
highs only around 60 on monday
northwest winds and nights in the 40s in
the las vegas valley that is going to be
a big
big change for us